[Musique]
cela fait maintenant plusieurs semaines
qu'ilon musk et sont lavabo ont pris
possession de Twitter depuis qu'il est à
la tête du réseau social l'homme a mis
en place de nombreux changements c'est
séparés de la plupart de ces salariés et
réactiver les comptes de Trump et Kanye
West étant dit que Facebook Instagram
Youtube et Twitter avait instauré un
système de lutte contre les fake news
sur le covid en signalant et supprimant
certains messages l'application laissera
désormais les internautes tweetés
librement depuis le 23 novembre Twitter
n’applique plus la politique relative
aux informations trompeuses concernant
la covid-19 les tweets sur le covid ne
seront donc plus contrôlés par la
PLATEFORME alors faut-il sanctionner des
propos complotistes sur les réseaux
personnel puisque vous à chaque fois
vous m'a postez comme si j'étais madame
vaccin moi j'ai jamais tweeté sur la
vaccination en revanche ce qu'ils sont
compte à vaccination ont beaucoup twitté
de manière un peu hystérique compulsive
et frénétique contre ce vaccin en
revanche moi ça reprend ce que je pense
depuis toujours de Elon Musk je pense
que c'est un danger public même si c'est
il est génial et que c'est voilà
mais indéniablement il est absolument
génial et visionnaire mais je pense que
de son génie de son génie justement il
va faire quelque chose de peut-être de
dangereux et je pense qu'effectivement
quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui sur les
fake news se propagent 8 fois plus vite
que les bonnes informations sur Twitter
alors je sais bien que aujourd'hui
peut-être tous les avis dans la presse
aussi c'est tellement de conneries dans
la presse je pense qu'ils disent plus de
conneries dans la presse que surtout je
crois pas ah si si vous vérifiez moi je
vous dis et je vous dis qu'il y a plus
de conneries dans la presse que sur
Twitter maintenant oui mais sauf qu'on
peut on peut porter plainte contre la
presse
ah bah si il y a des procédures allez
porter plainte contre contre une fake
news sur Twitter c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué Gilles c'est pas de la
diffamation ce sont des propos dirigés
sous couverts de journalistes et de
l'éditorialisation
regardez tout ce qui s'écrit sur Cyril
c'est de la mauvaise foi donc c'est pas
attaquable une fois dans ta vigile soit
honnête
attendez ici je suis le plus honnête
c'est ça son problème c'est qu'il est
trop honnête j'ai assez en étant honnête
que vous me reconnaissez le mérite
d'être ça
franchement laissez-moi juste ça mais
laissez-moi ça juste ça je peux pas
porter plainte contre la presse
aujourd'hui
c'est impossible c'est impossible c'est
impossible
il y a une info qui tient possible tu
fais quoi comme procès tu as dit que tu
avais fait plein de procès contre la
presse people c'est impossible
tu connais mal le sujet
il y a une dérive il y a une dérive de
la presse écrite qui publie des des
fausses informations sous couverts de
travail journalistique
mais on arrête pas de les dénoncer
regardez ce qui s'écrit sur Cyril c'est
des trucs mais ils vous envoient je
prends l'exemple de L'Express je vais le
citer il m'a envoyé des SMS les
journalistes de L'Express dans le sms je
voyais ce qu'ils allaient faire j'ai pas
répondu c'était alors vous êtes dirigé
on vous dit quoi dire mais ça fait 11
ans qu'on travaille ensemble jamais vous
ne m'avez dit quoi
c'est que l'Express a essayé de faire un
article sur ils ont appelé tout Paris
mais oui sauf que même les gens qui
travaillent plus avec moi on dit voilà
et tous les gens qui m'ont envoyé ils
m'ont dit m'ont dit que du bien de toi
donc ils nous ont dit non ça sert à rien
et ils ont été trouvés témoignages amis
et en plus il y a rien il y a rien de
mal en fait dans l'articotine bon
puisque et ils ont appelé tout le monde
qui a salé je voulais montrer d'ailleurs
il y a plein de questions est-ce que
est-ce que vous direz les gens là est-ce
que vous frappez les gens est-ce que
c'est vrai quand même carrément comme si
on a des réponses en plus bien sûr
évidemment est-ce que Cyril vous dit
quoi dire mais vous ne savez même pas ce
que je veux dire
mais voilà donc voilà donc je voulais
vous dire de procès à Monsieur
pas de la diffamation c'est plus subtil
Géraldine c'est ça le problème
une parenthèse et eux qui essaient de
faire du boss que je vous le dis
aujourd'hui j'ai eu encore mon
conseiller comme tout à l'heure il m'a
dit aujourd'hui quand tu mets Hanouna
dans un titre c'est ils explosent les
cette fois c'est quoi 20 de ce qu'ils
font ce qui est comme la presse essaie
de se sauver l'Express a fait un article
payant qu'ils ont relié sur Twitter et
tous les journalistes ils sont mis à 5
pour écrire ce torchon 5 et les gars ils
ont tous retweeté peut-être cinq ou six
extraits payants pour que les gens
payent donc je vous dis ne payez pas
alors je vais vous dire si vous voulez
je vais vous le dire demain il y a rien
de nouveau sous le soleil c'est nul à
chier et ils ont voilà ils ont trouvé
des gens ils ont trouvé une ancienne
chroniqueuse qui dit du bien de moi
Jessie qui était venu vous rappeler ou
pas
ici très sympa et c'est la seule qui qui
est cité puisque le reste voilà donc je
suis mort deux fois ces derniers ah oui
et j'ai divorcé deux fois aussi avec
Lola
alors j'ai été voir dans la chambre j'ai
dit non elle est toujours là
juste sur sur Elon Musk que je t'en
pense d'une moi je pense que là dessus
je suis d'accord avec lui parce que
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'une fausse
information sur le covid on ne sait pas
pourquoi est-ce que ce serait plus faux
que la voix officielle qui nous dit il
faut se vacciner etc je trouve très bien
qu'il y ait une un contrepoint sur ce
sujet et que les gens soient
susceptibles de se faire leur propre
avis mais que tout soit diffusé je n'ai
aucun problème avec ça parce qu'on
pensait les spectateurs et Emilio oui
voilà 69% oui bravo moi aussi je suis je
suis je suis je suis assez d'accord je
suis d'accord avec les téléspectateurs
c'est une excellente nouvelle moi depuis
le début du covid j'hallucine qu'à
chaque fois non non je suis pas choqué
par les c'était non bon c'est pas grave
mais oui depuis le début du covid je
suis choqué j'hallucine du du fait qu'en
fait dès qu'on met une story avec le mot
covid vaccin masque
avertissement automatiquement c'est
quand même pas réseau social qui va nous
dicter ce qu'on doit penser du covid
mais en même temps ça résume bien la
sorte de pensée unique que nous impose
certains médias depuis le début du covid
qui est insupportable et en fait qui
consiste à dire dès qu'on a une pensée
qui sort un peu déraille bah on est tout
de suite fou complotiste comme ça on est
hors sujet on est hors jeu directement
entier hein c'est insupportable je suis
désolé ça me choque quand on met le mot
masque dans un tweet on soit et on se
tape un message d'avertissement
automatiquement donc ils ont raison s'il
y a bien lieu on doit s'exprimer
librement c'est les réseaux sinon c'est
la dictature c'est la censure bah oui
parce que c'est vrai que sur Twitter on
nous a prêté les gens ont été traités de
complotistes mais on se voit on voit
bien avec les années qui sont passées
depuis deux ans bien sûr que tu sens que
que le Pass sanitaire il a été là et on
disait non il y aura jamais de passe
sanitaire tu es complotiste en vaccinera
jamais les enfants tes complotistes et
on se baladera jamais avec un masque
dans la rue en plein air tu es
complotiste et à chaque fois qu'on a été
traité de complotiste Péronne est un fou
Raoul est un fou l'hiver mectine c'est
pas vrai ça n'existe pas et on voit
aujourd'hui que tous ces mecs là on leur
donne finalement raison et on nous
pendant des années regardez dans les
autres pays quoi
tu vas lui mettre des plaques
devant la Commission des médecins et on
leur a dit bah finalement
je disais je m'en fous de ce qui se
passe là-bas je m'en fous et on dit non
c'est important ce qui se passe là-bas
tous les soignants dans tous les autres
pays du monde entier ils ont été
réintégrés pas chez nous pourquoi on
fait pas comme le monde entier après tu
demandes pas parce que je le connais pas
je connais personne je connais que vous
moi
ce que je demande la vidéo Marie Bigard
là dessus ou pas
[Applaudissements]
parce que je vous parle là